[Music]
the next-gen console war is now in full
swing and if you want to stay ahead of
the curve you need to pick a side
whether you enjoy playing games or
watching movies Microsoft's Xbox one has
got you covered this next-gen device is
the all-in-one media machine for your
living room with a strong lineup of
games you can buy right now and a whole
host of apps that let you enjoy and
share your favorite media with friends
the Xbox one isn't even a year old and
already it supports a diverse selection
of games for players of all stripes to
enjoy if you like having fun for
instance there's Dead Rising 3 with its
massive hordes of zombies and outlandish
weapon combinations if you need even
more blood guts and gore in your diet
the Xbox one has you covered with killer
instinct and Ryse son of Rome that's not
to say Xbox one doesn't have plenty of
family-friendly options as well
including zoo tycoon and Just Dance 2014
all this doesn't even include all the
big budget blockbusters available on
Xbox one right now I'm talking about
call of duty ghosts Forza Motorsport 5
Assassin's Creed 4 Black Flag and Madden
NFL 25 the library for Xbox one is
already strong and in 2014 it will only
grow stronger destiny and titanfall are
on deck if you want to run around with
guns causing 110 destruction both of
these blockbuster shooters come from
prestigious backgrounds destiny is the
first post Halo game from the now
independent studio Bungie while
titanfall is being developed by Respawn
Entertainment a studio built by Call of
Duty veterans motor Gear Solid 5 Ground
zeroes and watchdogs are also on deck if
you want to sneak around with guns
causing wanton destruction ground zeroes
is the latest in the long-running Metal
Gear Solid series and signals the
franchise's first foray into an open
world style of game watch dogs is
similarly open-world with a recreation
of Chicago which you control and a
voyeurism friendly multiplayer mode next
let's talk about the hardware
[Music]
one of the most disruptive pieces of
hardware to be introduced into the world
of video games has to be the Kinect when
it first arrived on the Xbox 360 it was
to be fair unwieldy and unresponsive but
Microsoft has been hard at work refining
this technology and molding it into a
truly complimentary device for console
owners currently the uses for Kinect are
limited outside of navigating the
consoles core media functions but
Microsoft has demonstrated its
commitment to this forward-thinking
technology that will likely become
second nature for gamers in the coming
year the Xbox one itself is a little bit
bigger than the Xbox 360 and is every
bit as sleek and shiny as a certain
other black next-gen console on the
market by using the consoles HDMI
pass-through technology you can enjoy
cable or satellite television with the
additional benefit of accessing the Xbox
one's numerous apps such as Internet
Explorer and Skype at the same time
the Xbox one controller subscribes to
the if it ain't broke don't fix it
school of design with a black matte
finish that feels great in your hands
the addition of Rumble to the left and
right triggers provides a fantastic
sense of weight and force such as when
you're speeding down the Raceway or
bashing a zombies brains out it's
important to note that both the Xbox one
and the PlayStation 4 will require a
paid subscription to access the entirety
of their online features if you're
willing to pay the piper which you must
if you're willing to buy a next-gen
console then you will gain access to an
impressive lineup of media apps
including Netflix YouTube and ESPN if
you're more interested in creating media
rather than consuming it the upload
studio app is a software suite that lets
you capture edit and upload gameplay
clips all within the Xbox one buying an
Xbox one today means buying a powerful
well-rounded machine that sports a great
lineup of games and a suite of apps that
enhance your games and movies rather
than distract from them the potential of
Kinect can also not be understated
either as a complement to your gaming
controls or is an entirely different way
to play together these elements make
Microsoft's Xbox one a great choice for
your next gen purchase
[Music]